[Music]
welcome podcast all right and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
special anniversary episode number 75
and it's another glorious Sunday and we
are back at the roundtable on the Lord's
Day I'm extremely excited about our
special guests so we're gonna get right
into it I want to introduce the Lord who
I had the absolute pleasure of meeting
at e3 2018 through our good friend on
the realm Lord Mike Ibarra not only is
this Lord a true gamer and one of the
great minds in our industry in regards
to network infrastructure his
contributions also include the foresight
to have managed the best talent of
triple a game design and software
engineering introducing the general
manager and current head of Xbox Live at
Microsoft the Lord of gaming invention
mix reality and the only Lord able to
spot land a fortnight gladder in real
life at party we're introducing the
future of xbox live making his debut
into the realm of the Lord's my man Lord
Dan McCullough how you doing sir amazing
have you been long overdue you are Lord
in your realm it's only right we show
you the proper respect here at the round
table so are you ready to get into this
I'm ready alright he's ready with the
lowest of course you know we have the
Four Horsemen of gaming those usual
suspects at the round table
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the half of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir doing
pretty good and here's that time where
Lord King David says how energetic I
said
exactly you are on it right now I'd know
that 5-hour energy is right there's a
new table you gotta pop it
I'm loving this I'm loving this good we
have our most technical Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Damas mr. off my profile Illuminati and
Lord patreon of the iron bake my man
Lord sovereign are you doing sir what's
good guys doing good I've been up since
6:00 a.m. today no you absolutely had
some issues going on in the background
so it was good that she was able to
power through and I get I think that
Lord Lord there might be going through
some - yeah absolutely and of course you
know we have the Incredible Hulk of this
aka excess gamer hmm the lord of combat
sports who was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is to get money game up
Oh beloved Lord King how you doing sir
I'm doing fantastic this is a wonderful
day trust me I've been looking forward
to this day I met this young gentleman
at a rooftop party could not wait to get
him on the show absolute pleasure that's
what's up and of course you know we have
the gaming ninja himself this shinobi
Lord kognito spreading that realness in
the realm of the ILP not telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear so before we get into what you
only get into which with the Lords of
plan I want to start off with Nord Dan
his video game system history his
extremely impressive career at Microsoft
of over 13 years and of course would let
him to become the latest Lord of Xbox
Live by far
the best online infrastructure in gaming
today so Lord then let's start from the
very beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had and
what Gatchina gave me oh yeah
so I started off with probably my Atari
2600 was probably the first system that
I really played you know I remember
playing River raid and just you know
asking my dad like I'm from Canada and
my games in a Canadian tires were more
of these Atari games you know and never
you know I had my buddy had a like a
calico vision and all this yeah the
caligula that's what I started with oh
so I played a lot of that and then you
know when the the Nintendo came out in
the Sega Master System you know that's
when it was just it was game over like
kids now let me ask you a question
remember the 6a it kind of what trouble
graphics Sega originated those cue cards
nobody had the little cards did you have
any of those card games oh man I don't
think I did okay you know it's or those
things I just did you see if just you
know Sega did a great job
you know when Genesis everything but
like no one seems to have the Master
System like I talk about this all the
time no one's like that was built in
member that crap
remembering that because awesome so I
played that loud but like you know I
remember my grandma got the the Nintendo
one that had the triple Mario right had
the Mario the tracking feel that duck
hunt honest we would play on that stupid
mat and race and we were so freaking
good but you know we would just play the
Nintendo for hours and hours I remember
like it was my great
TV that we would always play on man we
would always kind of like leave it on
pause in channel hoping that he would
like turn it off as we like for the
light so he wouldn't know it was all cuz
you know maybe he wants to save power
because we're like in the middle of like
a Dragon Warrior game or but man we
played non-stop and then I went you know
I think it turned you know I remember
saving up for the Super Nintendo and I
used to go to Toys R Us to play Super
Mario World salut over and over and over
again I was like man I'm like 20 bucks
off I can do this you know that I
finally know that's just Aluva because
we had our love clowns on and like
obviously we all know the history kind
of right now what's going on with Toys R
Us and it's such an emotional thing that
it's gone so it's just like when you
said that I remember doing the same
things like you in in Toys Richard able
to go in and literally demo these things
as well as toys and stuff like that it
was just an awesome time and staff
people who never got a chance to
experience wish she would have had like
some kind of login system because I've
got to put in Xbox Live heritage just
reach in he said which I had an
engagement this is how does it was
throat Wed
Mortal Kombat Super Nintendo and now
I'll say this the genesis version of
Mortal Kombat was better because it had
blood I agree correct I had the Super
Nintendo at that time okay remember I'm
like I think I want to buy this game I
love the arcade game I would write I
would take note cards to boys or us with
my moves written on them so be exact I'm
like and we would literally light up
just like you would at the arcade at
Toys R Us and kids were like hey if you
win you stay on the controller
I used to go to nobody beats The Wiz
plating your deal for hours on end today
are you gonna buy this no actually mimic
like arcade culture because like that's
how I was like you know you guy was on a
control or in this case the control
instead of the arcade stick but you know
me and you you sit there and you gotta
put the next guy put his quarter up and
he was next in line and it just kept
going and it's funny [ __ ] brought that
it sucks
you know I when I got my when I finally
did buy my super which was like probably
you know couple weeks after it launched
I had as a birthday party I had two of
my buddies come over and our goal and I
had the Super Mario World strategy guide
the thick one I had gone to Nintendo
Power
Nintendo Power and we had read that they
cover to cover before the Nintendo was
even available right like that's like a
month before and it was our job to beat
that game the night we got it and we
just you know I love the passion about
la you hear to your voice yeah you take
it at the back man so they're from Super
Nintendo where did you kind of elevate
to after that was the next direction you
know I was getting really into PC gaming
at that time was play some Starcraft and
some quake and and other things and so I
got a 64 during the Goldeneye era
tomorrow 64 and all those games but then
I then I went to PlayStation okay okay
yes Wow
PlayStation Eye plays you know I think
Metal Gear Solid is probably small I'm a
big Final Fantasy died to jump in did
you play did you play not at it cuz
you're the Final Fantasy Google here
I've beat them all but six okay what was
your impression of dying so as we get we
got it's my second favorite
really whatever stolen oj7 your favorite
mmm no tactics is my favorite okay it is
just like I've I've got I played every
Final Fantasy as well nice but Knight is
the world where I got lost in that world
I was like I want to live in this world
I got lost in three I love 3 that's when
they introduced a job system right yeah
yeah it was three that's to me that's
why I got that octal pad travel that
that is yeah so I don't know I just got
really nostalgic when you just said it
was a return to like fantasy right after
seven nine nine the main character is a
dame that's right nice yeah so that was
a big weight you know back at the ot2
Tendo days like Dragon Warrior was one
of my favorite years I got like hours in
that game you know that was very classic
JRPG and so absolutely stay with those
games and so I went for a PlayStation
and then I you know I got original Xbox
and coefficient 2 just because I could I
just need to play everything it's so
absolutely I couldn't get enough
no no Sega Saturn no no I had a Sega
Saturn in college it's my favorite story
is go disc the the door you know the top
door that comes down and that goes in
and if it doesn't stay it it won't spin
it won't spin right yeah we we played
our entire college career honor honor no
sorry I talked about Dreamcast right now
okay okay the top cool books on top of
the Dreamcast it would keep it down and
remember they had that stupid thing on
the controllers when you were play like
freaking 2k football and see that was
your plays it well the vmu so you can
pick your football history of
- oh I like that now you're talking I
was so damn happy Madden India I played
19 with my son a lot in the past week
but nah mine was all like hey I love the
original latech Tecmo Bowl and all that
stuff I did have it I did not all go
over the bill still will be upset but
it's okay it's did you play action
football it's super play action football
if you guys played those amazing and
then I waited to like you know obviously
the the Madden's and the two K's and all
those games but I know I always liked
football though the wood game I just
loved all the consoles it they just do
all right let me ask for you Japan
soccer football question now a lot of
people in video game history consider
that NFL 2k I believe it was was it 2k v
that one was what like one of the
greatest ones and I believe that's the
one that had the ESPN integration and it
had um the actual replays remember Lord
King we was so amazed by watching the
ESPN series because it would have
replays of gameplay during the game with
Chris and Rubin you did you have that
one I did I played I played all the two
K's all the man it's the to be my
favorite I think it's still night med in
99 and not because it was better than
others but that was like every wow that
was my freshman year in college and we
just did the full all everyone in our
dorms play and there was like a pool of
100 bucks and like everyone played mad
we had rules because in that in the
night night version there was a trick
play a trick but the one rule it was
like so we called it the no fake punt we
do
madam and it's called baby Paul listen I
would you know we're a big battle in the
house we get into bettin on these games
and not cash but we're betting
humiliating things Lord he struggled for
weeks trying to figure out how to defend
baby Paul baby Paul was undefendable
alright we had this match and we're
playing and we're going and we're at it
and he really thought this is the time
that he had me praise Joe Montana I had
the 49ers and I dropped back there was
no more time on the clock he was up by
six points I dropped back in his washers
coming they're coming they're like we
got him in his heart he knew he had me I
launched that ball from my insole
control that's why that was my favorite
ever I love that and they had he had the
one cheap play the halfback pass that
was complete it was completely you could
just run to everybody I just kept doing
it I love doing Oh does a developer
because the matrix of the testing is
just so many ways to do right like you
could have a crazy player that all he
does is like zigzag back and forth away
you got to figured out like how would
that work right so there's every game
though it always have you know before
you could patch games right where I was
like here here's the game you know let
you play that one I'm glad you actually
mentioned like the technical side of on
the back end because you're right like
if you really look people give you know
football games a bad name recently you
know I'm saying but it's right because
you have to defend from all these
different possibilities AI combinations
on defense and offense and then you know
it has to be tough especially back then
like you said there was no patching you
know what once the game ship that was it
like you know so at the end of the day
you you can now feel for the dev because
it's like wow like we can see that one
coming you know that kind of thing NFL
Blitz
we're so popular right because it's six
things you can do right yes it's a lot
more just craziness but probably a lot
easier to be G's going little diverse
you guys cuz you started yet to me a
master system they'd superintendent all
that stuff so the 32-bit era was out cuz
no three do and no Jaguar we considered
[Laughter]
but I wanted to ask about an older
system that I even mention Coleco and
all that crazy re that's awesome I
wanted to ask him trying to get some
love for a turbo graphics 16 any turbo
graphics or experience or any television
like everything that everyone had but
you know I just didn't have access to
one and because I still remember like
early pcs and Apple twos I'd gave on
everything like a game I would do it
right like it you know I got to a point
where so like I've played everything
like obviously uber like that was kind
of like the if there's a if there's a
game I don't care what it is okay if
it's Aladdin or Barbie it was amazing
I had the Genesis love I mean the
animation in the Super Nintendo was
great I just I don't know it was like
that was at that point when it was come
having this battle between like who can
make the better versions the music was
always better on Super Nintendo
every time but Genesis had that
something had a little bit of graphic
magic absolutely they shout depravities
yeah he's like remember Tommy Lasorda
baseball you got to the chat really
bring it up some class it's bad that's
what's up
all right cool so that we got that in
the console history whatever so long
you've had I want to get into like your
career now you've had such a diverse
gaming career like so like what drove
you to get now into the industry and you
know let's start from the beginning with
that yeah so I knew I wanted to be games
this is the beginning like since I was a
kid it was like I should that's what I
love this is what I want to do yeah I
got it to programming when I was like 12
oh god bless you God bless you I tried
that okay I told you a lot I started
like you know if you remember the QBasic
games that came with das uh yes the
snake game in the river yes and those
politicals games came with the code and
so you can start tweaking with them and
start doing things I remember the first
day I ever did was make it so that every
time I lost my bandana it hits a target
no matter what I do and I would play
with my friends gosh you're so good at
this I was like this is awesome this is
what I want to do it so I knew I was
gonna you know go into gaming and so
it's freezin mm-hm
at some point I just knew I would work
for Microsoft and this is pre this is
pre Xbox yeah talking could when you
talking that though those Cubase joints
and you talk at Apple to you like this
before they even thought about getting
you through the game
and so but you know they had flight Sid
back then and they were starting
something astronauts call was getting
thought talked about those types of
things it's alright but it was like hey
I'm gonna work at myself well the gaming
industry problem was always the same and
it remains the same it's every job
application every job description says
must have shipped three triple-a titles
Wow today it's much easier anyone can
break out unity and try to make a game
and get it and truthfully make a game
release it on Android and iOS and
selling hey here's a game whether people
are playing or not you understand the
entire process you delivered it and you
have a game back there that's a week I
waited to Microsoft and I got a job oh
there it is some really bad things
inside the chat and I don't want to
enter work his story at ball because
boss moves has just said Sega this sonic
was lame-o dispel that Mario bandicoot
Sonic the heroes of those platforms they
all work great like let's be honest like
those are all classy games that everyone
should play but go back so you know I
started at Microsoft I had an internship
oh and college kind of told me that I
think people really want to program
you're not you don't have that the
patience for program I still go to this
day but like right BOTS and scripts and
hacks for games which we're not gonna go
into too much but it's really you know I
really wanted to kind of more be the
process guy or leader or those types of
things so I I got a job to work on MSN
Messenger Rebecca geminus a message I
was a program manager there and I'd
worked on all the telco work and all of
the
I worked on the first time you could set
in a text message from yes foe to a fine
house a big deal and it you guys are not
to cut you but you guys really
penetrated the the work space because I
remember stand-in messenger was almost
like a prerequisite to communicate you
know I mean I I definitely remember
those days wow that's good continue
continue yeah it's kind of crazy right
like that was like a daily thing yes no
what does that make me slack I gotta get
to the gamey side so I applied to every
studio by yourself had to offer at the
time and at that time it was budgie fast
turn guys that did the flight and they
were working on a trade sim that never
released and then the ensemble guys that
would work out age yes
no I applied to all the studios I got
some good offers I mean I got offers for
most of them and I chose to go to turn
Ted because nothing I mean I liked cars
but I wasn't like a car guy I was more
GranTurismo guy back in the place yes
absolutely they were the leader back
then but then it was really bore they
were finishing up for two - and I wanted
to be there from the beginning
nice so I went over to Ted lots of
leadership changes happen and so I got
opportunities to you know step into some
leadership roles and really you know got
four to three out of the park is a
really good time where I got to be there
from the beginning to an end and really
no hit the first force of the shift on
time within budget you know we started
working on four to four and at that time
we were incubating connect and I was
asked to kind of start looking le hey
what could we do with connect with Forza
I started working with the connective a
lot and to be kind of
folio badger for all the cadet games now
let me slow you know this let me see one
sec did you gloss it over huge dick like
alright first of all what a shout-out
all Brad podcast cuz he asked this like
did you have any arm inclination as far
as to connect that the way would take
off and just like what was it like
managing that portfolio of connect
houses people don't realize like people
clown connect now a little bits kind of
like laughing a little bit but it was so
ahead of its time and actually a
financial success for Microsoft 2360 so
like talk about that so you know the
first demo we ever did for Kinect this
was crazy like we cracked open the
controller we soldered some wires onto
it that wet directly to the Kinect and
so basically the Kinect would track you
and then send that data to the
controller and pretend like it's a
controller if we do with burnout that
was a and all you could do is if we
detect that your right leg was forward
we thought you're pressing on the gas
pedal if you lead right and left we
would turn the see we left alright
that's it that's it Wow so you would
correspond those things to actually
interesting yeah that's before we had
read the ad like crazy code that could
do all the detection and all this stuff
and so we're like right there's
something here
and you know so what I was tasked with
was really like hey let's make sure
every see one of our game highlights
like a unique differentiation of this
platform was an interesting time where
Xbox was super hardcore it's it was it
was a dude bro box to the head
you know let stuff go to hello to
parties this was all about you know it
you know in Halo 3 still one of my
favorite games it's always to play Halo
3 in my office at work alright so when
we were working on this it was really
like hey we need to think differently
like we want to target everyone right
count like what the he was doing yes and
so we really want every you know we
wanted there to be something for
everyone so we a sports game we had I
love I love connect sports bag by the
way
so you know it [ __ ] you know it's still
like I I agree I think there was some
missteps and some other things like very
financially positive for the company
still the fastest you know selling you
know any really push to 362 you know
just the dominate a force of that
generation you know I'd say you know we
kind of put the core gamer second for a
little bit okay that's one of the
mistakes that you know turn into maybe
further mistakes in the next one yes you
are you gonna do you think it had to do
with more of the forced integration do
you think like because I remember when
during that time even motorsport which
you worked in it you buy the Xbox 360
title and if you guys remember Kingsoft
attic at the top there was a purple
label and it would say best place would
connect do yeah yeah did you think
because of that maybe the success and
you guys did hit the casual chronic so
we don't want to not give connected to
do the original connect was successful
but do you think that maybe I'm trying
to integrate too much was wet it kind of
aggravated the hardcore crowd a little
bit price is always gonna be a big
factor surprise to developer happiness
to anything to marketing campaigns
everything kind of puts it just know
there's no one figure to point at anyone
and it's more you know I think it's just
a lot of good learnings for us or just
you know what to do in the future it's a
you know I really enjoyed the time I
worked on connect even though I'll say
this I had little kids at a time it was
also to finally make a game that they
could think and play that's a good point
good point to forty questions are
connectivity before what all right that
look kick is gonna laugh at me this one
now when we first saw a connect it was
called project it's all shout out to all
these fine to use the way a project at
all shirt but our first better what I
like when I first saw it was
jaw-dropping for the standpoint I
believe they had peter molyneux list
I was favored late but whatever was
there was there little boy that little
boy the water sees his reflection yes
the devil like we don't know how they
doing it like that's real or it was just
a it was it was a hundred percent real
here's here's the funny things about I
mean outside of the peter molyneux
factor of I mean a big bullfrog games
guys Beckett awesome working I love
everything back so there was a type here
where we were all prototyping we didn't
know what we would do with it one
developer had a great idea of hey we
have a camera we have an IR sensor a we
have a normal camera well we can make a
video feed of your face and just
superimpose it on top of the reflection
in the water right when you looked at
what the little boy looks down
we'll just superpose your real face on
it it'll just blow your mind
yes he's doing it you're like the
perfect setting where I think it's a
picture of a lake you know but yes he
worked it and that was a you know that
was a fun project you know that they
were there's a lot of cadet games that
we didn't ship just because to quick
question for the chat every book seems
connect everyone the chat loves this for
some reason - I want I personally want
to know what your environment was also
did you on as far as the
stuff like that did you have anything to
do with that as far as the connect part
to and the second question and again
will finally move on from this is loss
now though he wanted to ask about
because you had kids like did you guys
and did that affect what you made foot
connect so to speak yeah I mean it's a
day of like it's easy when you make it a
game that's for you right like it's just
like like magic work out on the gears
franchise and that's like your favorite
game well it's perfect for you but like
now you need to tailor it for your
whatever like someone else it's it's
very hard so that was one of the thing
with connectors a sigh alright this is
kind of fun for me but is it fun for
others and so we started bringing we
start to really diversify the types of
people will bring in younger generations
you know my kids would come in and try
games like whatever it did it brought
everyone a different demographic that
was awesome like that's still true today
I think there's a lot of remnant of just
the way we try to be more inclusive of
things has been really positive I think
that it stems from that so you know I
the day it [ __ ] so I was in New York for
the big launch of connectiveness big
thing with like Mark Wahlberg and bunch
of others and last the day I got back
that Monday is the day I started working
on project for laser which became
hololens it so Durango and the next guy
gotcha okay so your answer my question
already which is pretty much at that
point so which leads me on to the next
segment which is kind of like you know
you got a lot of talents from you know
the engineering side programming side
you've got you got such a diverse
portfolio what I wanted to ask now is
you know Lord and the Lord of invention
that's what I call it sounds like and
mix reality so you've got a ton of like
patent projects and stuff like that so
my question is like what was your role
specifically with hololens and then
obviously the head of mix reality for
Xbox yeah so you know the biggest thing
was we just had a small team four or
five people I was like hey we just
revolutionized input now let's
revolutionize output it's a you know the
dream is still at some point I think all
of us we just want the holodeck so
anything that kind of you know my two
passions in life has all has been for a
long time it's push what's possible for
gaming Rachel I love games that push
that mold and try new things as long as
destiny would came out when one of our
custom do more like I you know I'm still
there still this game that is impossible
to make today that I that I want right
so anything like a cruise to that I love
the second one is a tea that accrues to
taking you to a whole different place so
creating a holodeck with your favorite
passion so anything I always want to
work on things that push it towards
those two things and so with hololens we
had a tiny team like four or five people
and we spent the first couple years just
hardware and writing pens and figuring
out as we came up with some super crude
hardware and you know I spent probably
four big was that battery four years on
that project before we ever told the
world we were working on it right Wow
really incubated that's right it for a
while you know it was it was very gaming
focus right I think lots of games on it
lots of those are these I got it
Greenland's I got ice all the gays it
was from a price point and from a tech
you know eight this year it's gonna be
Enterprise for a while and at some point
it will be more consumer right we kind
of had to pivot but I still the halo
Guardian oh yeah I remember I have a
story about that that was my project I
did the haul that stuff for that but
that was kind of the last like big game
we did for for hollows let me jump in
because uh yeah I remember that well I'm
assuming he also worked on that team
with you Dan yeah so I saw them so all I
remember was to 2015
and you guys the beauty now it's blown
away in me and coudl really tight and at
the time he's like hey man we've got
this halo demo halo he's like yeah you
gotta check it out
and we had it all set up you know it was
funny because I was all set to go at all
like all the rest of my fresh out said
send you to Sage and a couple other it
was select four or five of us Hado and I
was like part of them I care so they got
to see it then my date marked my time
for scheduling was like the next day
Sabo they're telling me what somebody's
like do you pull me to the side
Kanye's here like I ate Calle ro you got
to do it you got to see it but from all
the accounts shout out to uh Dan
McCaffrey I mean Ryan McCaffrey yet uh
he got a chance to see it with everyone
raved about your halo there's always
lots of celebrities that kind of roam it
you don't see a lot of them cuz you just
gotta go from like back door - back door
but like that day I mean I showed that
demo to Kanye to Steven Spielberg - you
know bunch of other saliva it was just
an interesting day because waiting this
crazy devil was long like it was yes
like ten minute parcel you're there for
half an hour like six day you'll be like
60 people I remember doing the bath and
going through the lie and in the devil
you got like this cool Cortana USB key
to head like I'm pressing it on and and
I started go to light I was like alright
there's five hours till the closes
there's no way zero way you're gonna go
if what lab even you guys are getting it
right yep
so here it's probably like another mile
of people it sounds like hey I just
start yeah like Cortana keys to all of
them let's say like
oh go do something else there's this you
know go play you know the new Zelda or
whatever that they were showing that you
it was the AR hololens
and zelda line was insane why is that
III yeah but people like da I'm gonna
risk it people that are running that
booth come to told me there's absolutely
no chance you're going to take their
word as the creator of it how did that
make you feel to see that line like I
mean I know it had to swell you up
inside with so much pride because that
line was inside I didn't even dare it
was I mean full credit
my assumption for the forever was just
well they're digital play Halo which
they should but then like by the third
day I knew a lot of them were there
because they had heard about this crazy
AR thing as well right and so it was
awesome like that project was just so
insanely I mean we recreated the inside
of you know a halo starship like you
were walking on like metal Grady you
like everything you know we spent so
much money on that like all that stuff
just gets tossed I don't know let's
bring that back to our studio and let's
just had them that'd be one of our
hallways you know it was very ambitious
man we were all super excited by this
unique approach to viewers at the time
you know VI was taken off and this was
something completely different like a
always completely definitely never see
anything like that I never meant seeing
that that a minecraft minecraft demo
yeah yeah just dis utilizing the world
so I understood like from the text or
the standpoint you you're absolutely
correct look there like it had to be no
cost effective for the consoles because
pretty nuts like we swapped demo at the
last minute
really before before you would live once
on it I mean that last me like maybe
like a couple days before but
to us that's very last minute yeah
absolutely there's a video I know if you
ever see that word I'm on stage for some
other event and I'm just a lien yes yes
I think that would get but we were going
to do but then the Minecraft team had
been working on this thing and they
pulled out all the stops at the last
minute it like truthfully like it was
just a better demo for that for that day
I said it got my attention that was for
sure absolutely
at least like I said was very ambitious
in like I said salud to you guys for a
10 minute so right now just remains in
the what you call space the like the
enterprise space or just just kind of go
on from now so happy but yeah like I
think the the the the target right now
really is about like the information
worker and a little bit you know just
like computers were originally right
like in two thousand dollars that's
offer for everyone right the original
design never changed it at all have you
been able to extreme line anything in
terms of the hardware to make it more
company pretty exclusive all the
hardware right like smaller and cheaper
right kind of what you can do it with
with hardware's goes on it here you hear
that a long ok that's cool but how can
we make a smaller and cheaper it was
always like is there are we at the right
stage in humanity where we could
actually like we had those subproblems
like there's you know there's two types
of problems that we work on there's late
night pay for dinners of hard work and a
long time problems and then there's we
just need to invent and create miracles
that just haven't happened yet work I
like like Tesla he could have done that
20 years ago like there's a fax
batteries
were that small and that good right like
you just like you know it's just
remember those bag lights used to have
it oh yeah oh yeah like that that's what
power that super battery no you're right
all right sometimes like I said it's
like you said it's just like acceptance
the world has to be ready but more
importantly the tech has to be ready and
there's got to be the right price point
so it's like a perfect marriage of all
these different things oh if all I had
the car I thought it was amazing all I
would say is if you guys did kind of
come back to it was that at this point
probably needs to be untethered you
don't mean as far as the Guardians and
then the other one okay I'm sorry I was
gonna pay the money for it I'm gonna pay
the two grand for it right but then when
I found out that all that cool stuff
that you were doing really doesn't come
in that pack what you call the field of
vision I don't people sitting if I can
somewhat just looking for you it's far
as getting more of a a view but that's
pretty much it I mean it was really
there and hopefully it does come back I
thought you know VR was really taking
off and we did a lot of VR stuff with it
and you know we didn't know originally
when we were started like you know which
direction we would go and so we had lots
of demos and lots of different that's
why I really got to the ARP rmr space
but it was really always for me centered
around gaming and so as I see he's
really moved towards enterprise which
you know I was a big I push for that a
lot because I thought it was right for
the product knowing that it wasn't gonna
be my passion anymore right because of
it but I think I think it was the right
decision so sometimes you gotta
understand you let your baby go so that
I would have move on to own disc or you
know and obviously an Xbox Live
obviously in April of this year you guys
announced and introduced like that
marriage between
you actually personally on our Xbox Lou
honor this court and Xbox Live
integration so how did that process kind
of start yeah I mean you know I'm a huge
PC gamer like what do you get into like
the last like you know I PC game every
day and I've been the Me's gamer you
know since the mid 90s okay I still you
know I still play on my xbox and my
PlayStation all the time but you know PC
is kind of this big passion thing and so
you know disc or something I've used for
a long time and as I tried to really you
know continue to push Xbox Live into you
know as we grow the Xbox brand and what
we touch from the games perspective from
Network perspective from eco ecosystem
perspective we want to be everywhere
right like I think every game company
wants to be everywhere so it kind of
makes it you know disco was something or
like hey here's two great networks let's
see if we can get on you know talking to
each other and doing things so we
started with something just to kind of
test the water see if this is something
people want so it's just a very light
touch you don't just kind of see
presents across networks and see where
where that goes and so that was you know
we were talking to them you know we just
reached out to them like hey what do you
think of this it's fun because good you
know their preferred method of
communication is this thing called
discord which it so it was just funny
all of our conversations we're having
all these like important business
decisions you know it worked great so it
was like it was just kind of a fun
change for me
yeah that's pretty cool because
obviously you know in the PCs first of
all in the Xbox space how you guys have
really been pushing integration
cross-play playing it where that kind of
stuff and obviously we know how huge
this court is I mean just recently as
much as last week's ILP we talked about
it you know how they've now started
their own stuff all in store and on
launcher and stuff like that on PC and
just to see that crow that's like over
150 ml like they're really big out here
it'd just be selfishly you know I
wouldn't mind discord on all platforms
and integrate it together you know but
[Music]
boy do they need you Lord Anse
we talked about that I wanted to get to
that story of the the Xbox Live type
Genesis thing that I liked that sparked
it when he was playing with all the
people in the projector
I was really enthused by this story give
me give me something else and I remember
all right remember you said yeah we were
talking about how so when I worked at
turn 10 on the for summer sport series
they had this huge team space with like
a huge 4k projector like a sick receiver
like amazing speaker systems huge
subwoofers and I remember you know I was
pretty young in my career and I remember
asking Alan Hartman this to imagine like
hey do you mind if I like great heads
over here on Friday nights and just like
huge halo 3 and we had all of these like
super early alphas that were internal
for like almost a year before the game
came out and we were good like we played
everything every day before the game
came out so when the game came out it
was even funny right so you were Loki
the cheat code on Xbox Live first time
where everyone else is what's funny
because people always ask really hey
what can you hook me up with I'm like
well I can maybe boost your gamer score
but that's kind of shady oak is like
I'll just be sure that you always get
match-made against people that are very
good like 25 people everyone bring food
we'd set up TVs all around this room and
we would just have a halo night from
9:00 p.m. to 4:00 in the morning
this is why I had to hear this when he
said it on air because when he said it
that's when I think that's what we
started really blonde because I was
listening to the story I was like wait a
second I really got listen to this
because this is what we did but he did
it on a grander scale we old-school with
with TVs it you know the lab a couple
ethernet cables yeah when I left certain
I said I can't do this on my house hey
bring your TV oh you know I I had little
kids they'd be upstairs sleeping I got
like 20 rowdy dudes outside you
literally come that that's the origin of
the lords you don't say before and all
that good stuff you know that was the
way we did he had brought four TV's over
we had like I said that came a little
late connection and it was just like I
don't know how a mom that with us cuz it
was like you know 50 to 20 you know yeah
man like it was just absolute man is we
had so much fun for hours apart yeah
quick question because Lord William
screams asked and he just said um any
chance we could ask about YouTube live
YouTube live streaming from Xbox Live
Xbox or is that a better which good
we're talking with everyone like we
really watch it label what gamers yes
hate that feature it's a YouTube
probably not because Microsoft
approached I booked at a Micah bar
actually was on on the Xbox two podcast
and they asked and that same question
it's it's it seems like it's more of a
Google thing than yeah yeah and at the
end of the day let's be real like I
remember I was so angry this has nothing
to do with Xbox what remember how long
it took for the YouTube app just to even
update and get 4k like it took forever
so again love this is really cool let's
keep it 100
really
cool history so Lord then we got to ask
you the question in the ask o the Lord
took them to the round Andy those top
five games or franchises of all time
Lord I think you know unless you gelled
a fan I think link to the past is
probably still my number one game at
Walter Oh link to the past
yeah you gotta talk to me about that you
looked now are you to the history isn't
that the one where you standing at the
end of the game with with what was it
you had to hit him back with something
that was not the norm but you normally
don't do I think it was the fairy
catcher thing wasn't it or a bottle or
something like that that's not the final
thought I'll get it that's the midway
get it before you oh yes okay so break
us down
why that's what are you great I think
this got me thinking because I mentioned
the strategy guide earlier there was
this Nintendo Power thing where if you
re subbed for 12 month date they sent
you one of five strategy guys there was
a Mario World one and late to the past
one to other ones I don't member another
one that has just bunch of cheat codes
right bunch of like codes that you could
use in the game or tricks and some
reason my order got messed up and I got
all five guides but I followed the guide
page to page or link to the past it did
everything hundred percent every day man
I loved every minute of it and I've
replayed that game if you played between
two worlds on the 3d assets lover like
it right it's so like I've played those
games you know I love ocarina I've
beaten breath of the wild I haven't my
in my basement cave I have a poster of
the one that goes with breath and wild I
have my next
all the shrines that I've completed
always run up to me really dad I
complete another shrine that's probably
still you know my should go ha that's
whether you go alright so we got that
what else give me give me some community
I have to go back to World of Warcraft
just because I spend hours in that game
and it's still to this day just
something that I I have so many amazing
memories just not playing that game you
know then it's halo 3 whoa you've
mentioned it three thousand oh like I
know I beat it with all skulls I played
the crap out of the multiplayer there
was just something just magical about
that game it just it just worked right
for me this will be a kind of a weird
one I go in this but soldier fortune to
on the PC okay - first-person shooter of
all whoa what is this member me like a
soldier of fortune is one of those games
where there's like there remember you
know people's heads off legs off that
was the Ghul system is where I was call
back the most pixel accurate
first-person shooter at the time like it
was like your cursor was literally one
pixel the center of your screen and it
was just deliciously fluid and I
probably played that you know 10,000
hours and I was in a gilded clan
whatever it was it leaves it did all all
kinds of stuff it so we we had a lot of
fun with it
uh let's see I'd say probably Metal Gear
is probably my fifth which one wait
Solid is the franchise my my favorite
would the original stock now I played
all the original metal gears a bit yes
yes all the revenge all the you know I
love the second original one but so no
Gear Solid four police he should was
just the most seasoned attic thing I'd
ever played it's the best one
the last solid five if you haven't
played that like it's freaking great
yeah sure sure thanks of what it's
pretty short and you know the first hour
most people just couldn't get through
cuz it's just crazy weird and completely
different than the rest of the game yes
but those are probably it's on it's
because I have like my favorite games
that ipz they're like my favorite
moments because I I have to share at
least one go for it come on let's go
I had a friend who was a little bit
older than me when I was in high school
and he was in college and he dropped out
of college with bunch of his buddies and
it start this like little business well
add there the rented kind of an office
space and they had a land this was like
men like you know mid to late 90s
17-inch motors which were laying in say
that if they had Rainbow six Andrew
would go there and I kid you not
they're like an office table and we
would sit the office and we would draw
maps it would talk right we're gonna
start here you're gonna go here you're
gonna snipe for here you could do this
it was spent like half an hour preppy
and then we would go and like execute it
and I was like some of the best times
right I love the rainbow six Rainbow six
men oh man tremendous I was so happy
when they finally came to console it's
just like I heard so many good things
about it it would finally got over I
call my desktop right now yeah pudgy
pudgy experimental fortnight nice world
of warcraft because I'm trying you know
played a little expansion I can't play
that World of Warcraft anymore when I
started spending real-life money just to
get some braces yeah dick [ __ ] is real
shout-out to our Lord just good he had
some funny stories we caught Lord cake
on that back
yeah stories may I see you guys and it's
one of those games that I know how
amazing it looks in addicting and I have
to stay away because already have enough
problems for sure oh yeah I remember I
would get out of class and this is silly
but I would run home like literally I am
druggie
they like like what is wrong with me
like an adult but I would run home to
play this game
Wow I've played a lot yes I've been
addicted to luggage I've luggage but
I've never run hold for 80s that lets
you know but I see it man like I said I
listen the King I listed it you know
Lord just good and and all these you
know World of Warcraft fan base and it's
it's such a powerful effect on gamers
and me was something it still is you
don't say like just one of the most
addicting games Lord sovereign
indoctrinated in you know like anytime
you you share a drug they try to pass it
off I set up his world he made a
paddling I remember all of it I was with
him oh you gonna go here you're gonna go
here follow me and I had this warrior
that was like level fifty and he was
just starting out so I was going in
there chilling stuff in his dungeon with
him I was like don't worry just stay
back you love it you have a great time
like ten hours another now man I think
when you discovered it for yourself yeah
is that the same thing where I tried to
bring bunch of people there like but
because you're doing all the work for
them that's why I like gays that push
about like I had played pull-tab on
EverQuest
or the world worker really kind of said
it set up for me and that's why I always
get excited with the division destiny
and yeah that's mine just keep pushing
just keep pushing to what day we have
this game where like 10 million of us
are all play together absolutely that's
what destiny represents for me exactly
what you said well tremendous five now I
know your PC gamer primarily now you
know for the most part well that's a lot
of your history was that but as far as
the game consoles right the top 5 there
and wow that's guys systems console Sam
yeah it's tough that's the one you
bought yeah that's what I bought myself
that's what I plan to spend the most
time and therefore zeyu worked on I
probably say the original Nintendo after
that just sheer amount of hours like you
know now we have this concept of screen
time with our kids I like to get on the
screen or dad can I get on no ideally I
would spend like my mode would like to
school psych you look really nobody I
Lord saw what the title story is small
town in Quebec Canada
my cousin and I it is a town where you
could just as an eight-year-old kid you
can go anywhere you ride your bike
anywhere and do everything Saturday
mornings we would try to like a 5th
Avenue and just just because like six
stores that you've never heard of and we
would go to each store and say hey it's
Saturday it's the same day as always we
need two dollars and fifty cents between
us is there any work we can do and then
like
a stock stuff or do some like eight we
go to the 1/4 store the head rental gays
for $2 mm-hmm
we would rent whatever gave the guy said
we should get then they would go to
Dairy Queen and each get a 25 let's go
ahead to play and so we would rent just
garbage games played but we played that
game for 10 hours no matter how bad it
was you guys are both up there read so
let's go here's another fun Side Story
game a side-scrolling helicopter game I
don't rember the name of it but I did
speak English I love English Ted I spoke
French I come back we would always try
to browse the manuals but you know
whatever we could not get past the first
level of this game if we played for five
freaking hours were like what is wrong
with us
like what system wasn't shoplifting no
shoplifting came I don't think it was
now safe much like that here's the
craziest part they did something no
other game did the select button was a
usable button in the game wow rotated
the helicopter 180 degrees so you go
scroll left or like how can we can't go
back there my grandma who spoke English
it's just like is there any way to go
back it's just like it did see that like
rotating anything she's like well yeah
you can rotate it by pressing like like
it really didn't have any functionality
outside you are correct we got to get
the day with that game
you've got me aim like to be able to
turn it around so we'll use mode 7 or
was just just no that was side-scrolling
cuz he's saying register while he was
180 degrees so think dink was it what
was the game when you picked up the pass
was it left right so it's big that and
then when you scrolling right you have
to press select that it's roll left to
go back that's crazy that's a good NES
Super NES I'm saying you got 360 yeah
probably just first would I'd say 64
whoa the just because it changed
everything right like we would be
playing like Halo don't ever have
happened without Mario and without
Goldeneye you know just because when
Goldeneye came up I was playing quake
and I was playing with 40 people it was
awesome and then with my friends which I
didn't you know I did have Goldeneye
yeah they're like dude you go try go
light I went to the house of like really
[Laughter]
what I got into it I played you know
bighead paintball mode for what like it
was so so many things at 64 man not only
was it quote me from right on guys it
was the debut the for play attack kind
of embedded inside the system 64 also
had wouldn't the debut of the analog
stick in game console gaming yeah that
was the whole thing of four screens if
they were able to do the four screens
moving at a decent framerate
or the remote by Z oh yeah it was done
okay the framerate without the with
mischievousness yeah we could talk game
with you [ __ ] you know I didn't put the
water on there but like my Scorpio and
the games now today like I love it I
spend so much time on it and it's great
but this is do you a thanks for
answering this question we'll get into
the show and what the Lord's are playing
so um let's get into Lord day like what
are you playing
leasing like right now like what did you
plan yeah so play with my son what she
team was you know I grew up a Browns fan
which is plays the Seahawks I still play
a lot of pub G I see so there we go
I play for night with my kids sometimes
and then I you know I got into the World
of Warcraft expansion like I always play
the experiences though dalvik cuz stuff
that's that's bet they'll doubt law at
which claim in we the young lord is not
fair
the Kujawski he's completely due to it
but I understood the control son know
the game sucks he was busy doing other
things so I went to the other lords in
clarify this guy's i'ma clarify this
imma let him say
because I don't want to step on his toes
but I was a lot of stuff being on I was
on that so I did that it was confirmed I
put up a Twitter station y'all single
sovereign online is like seeing Halley's
Comet
so when you say moments you tell your
children that you saw this and I
screenshot it so it is true that's all
or things on you again no bomb chicken
Lord fraud is lying ID is he soft
doesn't exist
you're there going all right this is
called the fraud alert i'ma give you the
fraud alert and these these suspects
this week is on alert
first first we're gonna start with
myself Oh Lord King blue Kings a fraud
brah
all right let me give it out there let
me give a shout-out to low tactical Lord
micro failure and Lord hardcore taking
me to do trials in a nine oh yes my
ignorance in thinking that I was able to
do iron banner and jump over to trial
was a nice dude Lord King is a fraud let
me tell you that right now
I got give to their trials and these
guys did a best we got the one match we
got the one we went to the little Tower
and it was like yo check it out it's
beautiful and I'm like yeah I got this
we can see stuff went to the next match
and got thoroughly wiped no trials and
destiny is a whole different beast it
really is like you know yo y'all got
these cars right you know everybody has
cars and some cars have a thing called
sports mode right destiny I'm driving in
casual lane I hate sports mode by
jumping in trials of the night
and I got thoroughly thrashed and trash
and I said you know what I see you let
me change my character I see what they
doing I went not change to my hunt the
same effect nothing else changed bro I
was like you listen I'm holding I'm
holding you guys back I'm not doing this
I'm gonna get out of here I ran with my
tail between my legs and that's next
fraud I'm gonna give a shout-out to a
relative native fraud oh my friend yes
sir you my friend are super fraud
because we were playing in a game of we
was down to the 12 people I'm sorry
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
super fraud oh Lord brett-brett
but I'm not because we actually were in
pub G we he actually picked up this
plaque from a relative but I gotta say
slight fraud on the the Destiny because
he was supposed to play all week you say
you're gonna play with me on things you
can play with me like you won't play
like we gonna play we will get it done
but the idea of playing games is
probably like twice or three times a
week so that's not my disk so that's the
fraud alert this week and that's what
I've been playing dude I like that
destiny to usual I just got you know my
solstice gear just finishing up the
master works on fantastic escalation
protocol run last night at a shadow some
Lord Lord tactical park at this game
in the building sister katsu I forgot
unit week do not kill me
he gets all bad but I forget to tweet
him and need my screenshots Lord J funds
lord zero tog was in the building and
salute to the newest members of the IO
feed clam a pub G of our PPG Brethren
Lord dizzy Lord Reaper they are now
officially ILP claim so make sure you
show them to proper love if you see them
out on Xbox alive please please reach
out now saying and switch and to the
dismay of all my Monster Hunter fans the
ultimate edition of Revelations ultimate
or switch because obviously I'm gonna go
I'm at work a lot so that type of game
were to perfectly this I want to shut
out Lord of focus I'm in a Richard fogey
from undead labs but he gave me some
good advice
I'm messing around with the weapons I'm
trying to find my way you know I mean
baby noob Monster Hunter so that's me
like the hardest of the hardest core
like at first I had a misconception of
the game like I didn't know at least the
way the one on switch were like it's
like separate hunts so you go then you
got you little two dudes or whatever
whatever so right now I think I'm kind
of focused more on a long range down
right now cuz me with that broad sword
thing it's just not working you know
this I'm messing with that you know
saying getting my first kills and all
that so I'm actually like because it's
perfect for me or the goal which is
without trial explained like at home you
don't know at the end I have too many
time-consuming games and destiny is one
of them you know so I knew at home I'm
not gonna play that game you know as
much as you can give it the attention it
should that's pretty much what I did so
let's get into this polls this is being
moving on so last week's poll results
are in and the people have spoken to the
question in lieu of the recent
plagiarism issues by a former editor at
IGN who do you hold most responsible the
winner at 59% in a fairly convincing
4-way ILP poll is the former editor
stole on his own accord group coming in
at second place at only 24 percent was
you can't trust the biased media guru
the opposite of the vote was the IGN
didn't properly vet the edited group so
um actually in a very close last place
at 8% as the I did needs to pay their
employees more the Lord's who
participated in last week's poll Lord
Dan I know you try to stay clear
controversy but uh what do you think
about so fared up you just agrees with
the polls him you will get the Lord show
alright so on let's get into these
topics so instead of what we normally do
we were saying at the LP we got the
special guest Lord Danny
enter man so um pretty much what we're
gonna do is do a special we're gonna
bring back ask your Lord and do like a
special Q&A
melodia so I'm gonna set it off and just
start with the basics so like Lord a
like as the head of Xbox Live like the
being that the head like what's the
day-to-day life like what is like what
does that entail and the second part of
that question is what you think is the
biggest misconception gamers have about
how Xbox Live works it's very big
company corporate meetings and things
like that
but you know it consists of two halves
the stability and scalability of the
service right like hey make sure
holidays also for every what make sure I
see people come on it's a great
experience as we do more with it gaming
with mixer and all of these other things
that we have capability to support you
know for more users the other half is
spending on hey what could what do our
gamers want what can what features can
we do for them what they need to do it
as a global service right we have to
take it to account lots of different
things and so my day to day really is
about you know reviewing a lot of ideas
and kind of unblocking things making
sure we prioritize these correctly you
know looking at
everything from legal to PR to Varney
business - you know how will this affect
our business you know the other days you
know pretty expensive thing to keep
running for foreign gamers but something
that we're really proud of it's
something that we really you know want
to continue driving innovation something
from a misconception perspective yes
I think you know Lord and my xbox live
down fix it probably it's a lot more
complex than people think
inside there just because we all do it
in a small scale like hey right I hooked
up my network I got my four computers
working for my LAN party right yeah
absolutely you know would you have
millions of people hammer your service
what do you have bunch of hackers try to
break that you have you know lots of
different you know people's privacy
settings need to be right all of you
suppose it's a really complex service
that has to work across the world and
we're gamers we're not patient upset and
so it's gotta be fast it's gotta be
reliable perception is the amount of
people that are working it TWiki all the
actual service itself to always make it
better and faster it's pretty daunting
when you look at everything that's done
yeah makes me just think about how crazy
something like facebook but means
absolutely just to scale yeah exactly
absolutely yet you guys don't get enough
credit I mean obviously listen networks
go down things happen you know but again
you know for the most part you know we
recognize you guys as the premier online
platform for games you know absolutely I
mean
in the history really you know extends
itself and that is much preach the
second question I have and then I'll
open it up to the floor these are the
only two I got to selfishly ask all
right
so besides network stability which
always obviously we know it's been a
strength you know there's also these two
feature sets you have and one of them
obviously was the like the ability to
change your gamertag right so at the a
like it's very important because and
it's given you guys kind of edge over
the competition
so my question pertains to the process
behind gamertag retention like how long
is an older game attack kind of like
held in the system before it's
considered idle and like kind of similar
and re-release back out like kind of
similar what you guys did in like 2011
2016 when it was all these unused you
know games and stuff like that cuz my
boy play gaming addict is hurting right
now man he was to be a lord and
apparently I guess somewhat is idle so
how does that process work yeah it's a
good question so the process phase bunch
of times over the years and truthfully
us because we we've been looking at the
stats how long so what takes to create a
gamertag Brad you know we've looked at
the trends so now everyone has numbers
in their game attacks which is probably
not what they watch they're spending a
lot of time fighting the gamertag like
most people are landing on the gamertag
that they stick with after like 10 to 50
tries which is terrible because that's
ten things that they probably wish that
they would have had before right ended
up with it so you know battle that
discord they've done a different route
are on our UD tags with numbers if these
are that ways with hashtags and so we're
looking right now at what can we do in
the future to kind of make this awesome
for everyone while still celebrated
those that had their og tag right make
sure that that we do a good job there so
right now that we have different
policies but truthfully those are all
need to change and be updated to kind of
accommodate for this bigger
system that were that we want to do as a
an overhaul its own today it's kind of
reduced broad sweeping strokes of idle
users you know we do some you know
one-to-one basis but oh right now super
expensive ones that we do for like you
know you know there's you know a lot of
times to I think people think oh the
network owners are greedy PlayStation
charts for this we charge for this
Blizzard charges for this it's the
infrastructure costed use of these
changes or what's established very easy
but the the per user basis what
sometimes the manual process can be very
hard when it's someone else is using it
and we need to go and make sure you know
we're not pretty frustration with other
users as well so run you'll see some
good changes coming in all right nicely
gonna addict this hope could be some
changes on the way we like that that's
that's positive that's what's up so I'm
open it up all anybody could jump in
with questions yes I got to keep my yeah
my question is are you really looking
forward to the next systems because I
understand the limitations of this
system as far as the CPU power does that
affect the xbox live because I would
like to do like 50 man raids right you
know I'm used to World of Warcraft I
know when he plays World of Warcraft 50
man raises absolutely nothing you get a
1520 and y'all get to go and you're
going side so that stuff is possible and
I know that's possible because of the
CPU power of the PC I want to know is it
the infrastructure of how Xbox Live is
structured that has the limitations for
that or per se or is it the CPU power
of the systems yeah it's a good question
if you think about the CPUs that you
used to play 50 man raised when World of
Warcraft's came out
trust me the Xbox one CPU as much better
than though I played you know World of
Warcraft in 2003 on my who knows what
bag that right like a garbage heap and
it's less that it's less the service as
well like we would be totally happy with
having fifty milrays it's really the
developer the cultural developers there
just hasn't been a thing they gotta make
the 50 Ray things before you guys look
you know what they're having 15 great
parties so we might as well have up ours
250 no absolutely it's just a it's more
of just a console games just have it bid
headed Ed Ruscha I'm hoping anthem and
other games will start to push them up
but there's really nothing other console
that's stopping them from doing that I
guess um to expound on little Kings but
what about like look I think like pub G
right that's under control for myself
right now
like how amazing would it be like to
have your own server of just you know
the hundreds of people who know you
don't say like a private setting like
that to me would be so cool if they ever
thought about influencing it is that
more of a blue whole thing is right like
so god I have a good relationship with
blue hole and I'm a a partner so I'm
able to exceed custom server I guess so
everyone could do it all in pudgy so
when I do it so we would do that where
we would run person pub G birthdate
so that's a feature they could just
bring to the call you giving me hope
that excites me nice absolutely that low
an addict you need a question yeah I do
have a quick question when it comes to
you know obviously from time to time it
doesn't really happen a whole lot but
from time to time Xbox Live does have a
little hiccups with Fino party systems
sometimes having trouble logging in when
stuff like that hits the fan what's the
process yeah so we have some pretty
awesome tools that alert us and so
there's lots of things that happen and
there's always people there all call so
think
like they pretty much have pagers swords
are you one of the people with the pages
do anything with it afterwards right so
we do people that uh that are experts in
these cells so what what happens is our
automated stuff will kick off
notifications hey we're see some
dropouts or we're see some of this so
what should look into it
the first thing those people will do is
look at some of our tools and our tools
are plugged into everyday mmm Network
stack Twitter tweeting see a calls to
work all centers mostly so you'll see
spice like hey lots of people call us
before to Snug these up and all that
happens in within minutes at that point
a call is creative bridges created much
like this Google hangout these that
we're doing right now will jump into
this and like hey what do you think it
is what do we see what does it mean uh
telling us all right
let's wake some people up that's my job
it's it's that's kind of the process and
then it's like alright well let PR know
let's release a tweet we know what the
issue is we're looking into it and then
we go in and address it dead
what's the issues address and lots of
emails internally that get escalated and
they're all formatted awesome when it
started when it finish what the root
cause was all the charts and graphs and
all of this and then the next week when
the next Friday no orge document goes
out saying here's what the issue was
here's what was mitigated here's what
we're gonna do so it never happens again
here's the process we're gonna put a
place to further mitigated those types
of theses so it's you know it truthfully
services like this you have issues all
the time not I'd say 90 99 percent of
the issues never a show to a user like
you never see it right because little
face but that's just any large scale
right like I remember really something
about Google search results fail like
what out of
10,000 times or something but like they
recover and they give you something well
there's billions of people searching so
that means you know thousands of fail
every day but you don't see it because
they recover and so we do a lot of those
types of things where you know you maybe
did get it you know the right thing or
it maybe took a second longer than we'd
like to to us that's a failure but you
learn there's all kinds of different
fears the highest woods those are the
ones to get lots of emails lots of text
messages go out those are the ones were
like users can't log it or users got
knocked out of it I mean they don't get
address extremely fast but those are the
ones that a lot more people get woken up
you know we gotta go do that so right
now this is the tie with your most
pre-holiday stuff like we want to make
sure Paul D small could you're ready for
that rush your bodily yourself you see
all the imperfections of everything
you've done right right that's exactly
what ever it is a thousand times more
frustrating what's your oh do they
absolutely bet and in that affects like
something we you see that message
sometimes like Xbox Live core services
down like is that kind of like one of
those super high priority things as far
as this game okay guys everything from
identity decided your profile to dead
all the networking we do with other
partners and other games and like you
know did that the times what is truly
the Xbox Live services issue is you know
one of MIDI right like it's it there's
just so many complex things right was
like oh the operating system need to
update or this
third party think that rugs on this edge
server that lets you run a gateway from
you know India to this for those gamers
to have a good experience had a problem
renegades or so--but it's such a complex
thing that you know you never know yeah
absolutely it's going to happen it so
many factors so many variables
completely really understand you saying
let me get a choice Lee's do look at
released last Monday expansion after
fifteen years
this is there whatever eighth expansion
or whatever it is and look at that it
was the worst release they've had in a
long time play for the first two days
you know servers kept going down all of
that this is Blizzard the gods of doing
this for fifteen years so it's just to
show that like nothing against up it's
just a very complex thing and there's
you know things just go no I hate you
man I hate cuz I like I say you know
it's funny to see the Twitter rhetorics
of ah I can't believe it's down this is
supposed to be the best Network exactly
you know it's good someone from behind
it's easy
break it down for us to so we can
explain yes what's really going on
it's a job but it's it's what we do as
well right so might just work to die to
five no hold we do I want to gate it if
if I can't that's that's extremely
frustrating that's like it's like when
you go to a movie this was only happy to
be once movie there you paid you get
your popcorn and this is three goes
black you gotta assume that black
screens part of the film Lord saw your
up married you got a question for Lord
yeah or my questions more big picture
like we know that these next consoles
are coming within the next few years and
we know there's been talk that streaming
is going to be sort of an integral part
of what these next console generation of
accounts are specially Xbox arm rings to
the table so my question to you is how
does Xbox Live have to evolve to support
that sort of stuff is that is that I
mean I know it must be very exciting but
it must be something that it's a huge
task to undertake so at a kaaba's xbox
live looking in 2020 yeah I mean I think
Fortnight really exposed the stage at
all that both US PlayStation everyone
else have been working on in the
background like we all know cross-play
cross-connection
claims whatever you have with whoever
you want is what we all want to get
right like you know it's so I think
place I mean for tonight just exposed it
a little earlier than we had anticipated
to everyone which i think is great
because it that pushes everyone in the
right direction
it's 2020 there's a lot less oh you play
on that oh you have a hmm eat your
friends like I think it's more let's
gave tonight like I have a good example
of three fortnight for me was I bought
my PC and I was working and Phil Spencer
the the head of Xbox
okay and I accept it I start play see if
T's on my PC and we're talking or on our
boat and we're doing or things and
someone in our party says hey how do you
pick this up and Phil said or you press
Y it right daddy hit me my head oh
they're all the console right - I hadn't
even connected it like I never even
crossed all right it did matter we were
having fun we sounded great it played
great and that was magical right like
right we all what is that like what do
you have
here let's play together yes so that's
that's what I see the future it's just
less boundaries crust as pure gaming
that is who did that for you have Xbox
only begotten Son our Lord and Savior we
appreciate your spatula this is this is
Kings vision he's been preaching it for
a long time and that's what it's about
like bringing games together and in that
cross play and things of that nature is
great so I just want to double down on
soft question cassava so good he always
takes my questions yeah like you know
obviously I know you can't comment on
the rumors right and I'm saying because
obviously you're working on what you're
working on but in reference to obviously
one of them is a dedicated screening
console and what we hear you know say so
in regards to how like the network
speeds are involving and streaming is
currently handled by like mixer which is
like extremely low latency you can say
in my opinion spirit switch but that's
just me but um so like how far down the
road do you anticipate a future where
Xbox Live would possibly handle
streaming video games yeah I mean you
know it's a lot of interesting
infrastructure right like as we look at
how do we accommodate hundreds and
millions of people on whatever endpoints
that there are there's a lot of work
that just needs to happen just to be
able to stay up and stay fast right no
matter what they're doing I think game
streaming is a whole other system of
infrastructure that needs to be created
it's kind of side to Xbox Live we have a
dedicated team that is thinking about
all of that stuff and then how it
connects with us it's kind of the magic
sauce that we kind of bring to the table
and so I think you know there's just a
lot of innovation like I mean think
about your iPhone or whatever device
that you have now five years ago right
they had compared to what it has today
Thanks five years is insane right so our
technology today is increasingly expert
is increasing exponentially so we
we keep trying to think about like okay
here's what people are doing today what
are they doing five years from now eight
five years is so crazy to think about
like five years ago if I was said could
you play also triple a first-person
shooter on your cell phone people
laughed you out of the room and so five
years from now what aren't you doing or
whatever right so I think it's it's so
sensitive like we just try to establish
like you know just keep use that word
like infrastructure that's so open and
valuable so that whatever crazy new
thing our product Eve's dream up we're
just available for them right working
with developers it publishers hey what
are you thinking about what's that crazy
new Gabe you want to work then this
could take five years to release what
new tag do you need to support that and
let's go out there and support you Wow
yeah that's awesome man that is awesome
I got more gum come on Lord because yeah
let me run the show a personal question
for Dan I know they like you're an
inventor and you have patents and a lot
of your parents seem to be just are all
your patents Microsoft relator do you
have stuff that you've done worked on
yourself that you try to patent apart
from Microsoft I have it I mean I've
worked on other stuff I've release of
iOS and Android gears I'm not gonna tell
you the names of know all of my pets are
Kinect games and haulage related they're
all so I want to get it to actually
interaction with other teams at
Microsoft so what teams do you tend to
interact with the most like maybe the
platform team any interaction also with
I want a friend to the realm lower bills
still well from the backward
compatibility team and just interactions
like even what you know Lord Mike Ibarra
and and Phil Spurs like how often are
you interacting with your role
yeah so Mike's my boss and so I see him
every day
it's you know like four or five offices
from bite so it's hard to avoid them you
know so we have lots of weekly meetings
together we see each other a lot
probably more like every other week I
probably have some you know multiple
times but this you know I really
interact a lot with the game pass team
the mixers the hardware platform team
everything from enforcement to PR to
marketing to legal all of that stuff is
like my daily job so I interact with all
those chief so you know in our business
and so if it's Xbox you know talk about
those people I probably meet with folks
from the studios at least you know a
couple times a month
just to kind of you know see what what
they're working on and how we can better
work together and then our third party
team as well on the big titles that are
coming out this holiday making sure so
it's sort of a you know Xbox ladies the
center of it all so we kind of probably
interacted with so much so any love for
the back obviously they announced titles
and stuff like that you know I talked
with the a lot like their focus on a lot
of cool new stuff that's coming out too
so with that were there any issues as
far as the infrastructure because one
thing I thought was really cool you guys
don't get enough credit for is that
whole connection between 360 and Xbox
one and getting it to be on the same
networking getting us to recognize the
achievements and purchases and all of
that that's why I really salute those
guys like you don't feel still when
those guys because you know a lot of
other platforms aren't doing that you
know it's almost like a no game no
behind your yesterday discussion about
this we because of how we count people
on our network
now with someone is play a 360 game on
their Xbox one our system urine you're
playing on your 360 no different user
and truthfully to our back-end like we
know just because of how you got into it
but it's just it's a you know just the
way that's made it's like it's a full
simulation which is awesome yes nice
nice anyone jumping in question just
expand a little bit um question from the
chat they want to know like what's
what's the excitement level that
Microsoft around like these new studio
acquisitions and and you know from your
interactions with these studios like
what what's the general excitement level
about what's to come and you know that
you know being the new IP new games
coming and then you know obviously the
hard work the new hard work coming down
the pipeline what's the general feeling
around this stuff yeah everyone is super
pumped right like I think it's it's
really just showing that like hey we're
we're for real like this yeah we're not
slowing down I think you know everyone
is just Punk'd we're like I just I love
games I love more games and so the more
we could do to bring more together you
know we're just gonna continue doing
that so I think everyone is just super
jazzed it's almost like a second wind
has always done a great job before but
it's kind of moving for it at the same
speed yes right now we're trying to let
people know like no we're doubling down
we're going actually mirrors yeah that's
what we want to hear his game is because
it actually mirrors we had a they said
Lord Richard fogey from undead labs and
he literally said the same thing like
literally almost verbatim he was just
like hey super pumped and you know
Microsoft's not messing around you know
say that was the quote you know and um
it's really good to see you guys renewed
you know with that bigger net hey it's
game time and as Lord King said about
Phil Spencer
hashtag who did when it comes to you
know not necessarily things on Xbox Live
portion because I used to work for you
know a customer service so you guys get
blamed for a lot of stuff that's not
under your control like for instance
like a game like let's say destiny
crashes people call you
like expecting that it's your fault when
a particular game goes down or like you
know their servers went down what's the
what's one of the ones that you can
recognize when you see down that like
you automatically sim well we're going
to get phone calls over that one yeah I
mean it's it doesn't matter what it is
like can't find a show on Netflix it's
our but you know we we work really
closely with all the developers to try
to you know prevent that from happening
obviously but it idea of the day people
just assume you know like a game crash
is such an interesting one we're on the
PC when your game crashes yeah you blame
the game right every time but on the
console you always blame the console
crashes you go to your desktop yeah yeah
top is very brand and awesome yeah
whatever right but when you get crushes
or culturals like your back to the xbox
- it's like it crash do you do to the
dashboards like this is your culprit
[Applause]
that's a great bandwidth so always
Benjamin it's like as far as the early
adopters in involving with the times
like you guys the first wit like Gigabit
Ethernet ports you know um you always
have like extensive console connectivity
tests and obviously 5g Wi-Fi
connectivity as well which is features
we really like to really appreciate you
know so one thing no one's like now with
gamers having all these large down
download
okay assets and then even with some
games that have like data caps in this
area is whether they're air as well as
like the net neutrality situation like
do you think Xbox Live may ever try to
work in conjunction with ISPs to try to
alleviate these issues for gamers you
know all of the big players PlayStation
Netflix other things they'll talk with
ISPs right like they okay you know
there's a lot things that get done to
make sure that things are great I think
is just how different North America is
than the rest of the world
infrastructure in you know the way that
you pay for your internet your calves
all those things so remember we have to
be mindful of everyone because it
doesn't work the same everywhere so
there's a lot of things that we try to
do that like all this would benefit the
you know the California user but would
really suck for the European user right
so those balances as well you know I
think bandwidth is some that's not as
big of a deal as they used to I think
now you know it's still a big deal but I
think it's good you gotta start seeing
it continue to just increase to the
masses okay or whole but yeah we have
crazy SATs right there still people are
dialogue you know we we have like we're
you know the core gamers they have the
best internet possible but that's not
what everyone has and think about when
we were kids
well you have whatever your parents have
yes gamers they have whatever you know I
remember me it was like oh stop picking
up the full of my mother thought aliens
were landing she picked up the phone I
was playing MBA live with x-band oh my
god the alien
what are you talking about you know
better but it's you know it's so it
looks slow when you look at it right now
but when you look at just like I
mentioned look at five years ago
oh no it's super fast I guess like I
said well my focus was more on like how
obviously we you know these huge games
may have 4k assets you know that you
know Xbox 20x actually pushing that
narrative in the 4k space and just how
bigger the games are like gears Wars
like you know some of these games like
over a hundred you know when you
download all the assets
I guess my my question is more pertain
to that gamer who has the quest of speed
he left the band with the door open but
as far as I stay the ISP and I say hey
you know you kind of read you need a
lorry to do games those hundred gigs are
like you know is there any steps maybe
in the future that could be done to like
to help those guys yeah I mean there's
always conversations of like hey could
we you know build some CD ends or other
things that would be closer to the gamer
so that they could avoid some of the
costs and stuff
they you know those are all all those
conversations take time and money and
business involved in all I think I think
you know it'll get better we're gonna
continue doing is you've seen some
you've seen this where you know you
don't need to download the entire year
even more of that happening where you
know you you might download a huge demo
and then play for five minutes right
like that's no absolutely I think that's
fantastic I'm glad you mentioned that
believe it was you guys are calling it
either intelligent delivered a fast
delivery yeah I think it's really cool
because I didn't realize Lord Dan like
how much those different languages
actually as far as one size of the game
you know so on those oh that's a really
cool feature that Microsoft is pushing
and I like that because doesn't get
enough credit because that kind of
really helps to leave you you can just
get especially let's say you're a guy
that just wants to play almost
of the game or just the single-player
campaign if there's any way you guys can
break that up to that that would be
really really cool I like Microsoft kind
of pushing that in that space so very
very cool oh my little controversial get
it to it so you know obviously you know
the value of Xbox Live minigame we feel
it people feel tremendous value for it
and all the services it provides the
cloud saying you know you guys a 12-play
party chat cross playing play anywhere
however one of the hottest debates the
past two years regarding Xbox Live has
been the idea of console gamers having
to pay for online multiplayer so while
in contrast absolute PC gamers do not we
all know this is a business Lord and we
all know the revenue streams play a part
here but at the same time like however
do you think we will ever see a time
when there's like a tiered system for
Xbox Live we're kind of free online
multiplayer is the base and then maybe
all those additional great services are
added with pay tiers definitely you will
see changes we want to give users
different choices and there's gonna be
lots of different options going forward
now is there ever gonna be just a
straight-up free play ad I don't know
like that's something we need to go and
evaluate and see if it's the right thing
to do but will we offer different
options for users going forward totally
nice is back at his Nostradamus stop
listen he said this I don't know how
many podcasts ago but he said it and I
listened I said you know doesn't make a
hell of a lot of sense so and it even
makes more sense now so
just and obviously I can say we have all
these services and things like that I
know you know Xbox is real big on
engagement especially with things like
game pass and people were kind of
laughing like oh if it's a game pass you
know how is it gonna sell because
Microsoft and then we're looking at
these NPD numbers right and we're seeing
games like c @ d you see in games like
stated k win NPD once they're in that
service so i guess it was the question
kind of came from a combination of maybe
the merging of getting passed into the
xbox live tier system as well as a base
system of you know maybe people just
having maybe they don't have the party
chat aspect or whatever but they have
you know being able to play multiplayer
so it's just food for thought not try to
get anyone in trouble but we definitely
definitely respect that there could be
changes in the way according to Lord
answer that that is refreshing and
hopeful know that very last very last
question I have is um as one of the
first Lord here obviously Lord kicks off
and not at it because he's the young
wolf but from the early days of Xbox
Live I was there from the Alpha program
Yoji Xbox I had a little CD I had to
tack it elevated and the first games are
play was a MotoGP and Ghost Recon right
so I personally am very proud to see the
evolution of Xbox Live and all the
services involved now as you know with
your journey and you started a different
path until becoming now the Lord of Xbox
Live
like how was that watching that
evolution in that journey from the
beginning to now being a part of it in
the head of it like what's that like to
you you know
when AG Xbox was out I was big PC gamer
already you know okay I could see what
they were doing and I was getting
excited about it but it was like to me
at first it was like well they're just
playing catch-up on something I've had
on the PC for a while but what I saw in
you know what I think the reason the 360
was so apart so awesome is that they
made it dead simple right we're like yes
sure I had all that on the PC but I was
editing config files I was cellulite
we reach sixty made it like dad I think
that was the awesome thing to watch you
know as they brought in features that
now every service has your phone all
these things gamertags and pictures that
was some of the awesome stuff that I was
able to see and you know benefit from it
so now it's awesome to be a big part of
it after having be able to be benefit
you know for benefiting from it for so
long
absolutely I'm glad you said that you
know Lord damn because you know a lot of
you know sometimes a lot of the peace to
see he community kind of gives the Casa
community some flack you know and I glad
you said it from standing because you
come from both and you you kind of
engage in both and you've got a
tremendous history in PC gaming so it's
just like people don't understand like
hey why don't you just get the most
powerful this thing and some people have
to understand you know like you what you
just said you know as far as you know
they don't want to edit config files
they don't want to mess with drivers and
I said everything involved with PC is
that difficult at the same time
sometimes as a gamer the majority of
people just want to come home turn on a
box and it just works and you just log
in and then the whole process is
simplified so I'm glad you actually said
that because that is a huge argument for
why people still remain on console and
why a lot of things that happening in
the console space that it doesn't seem
like it's going away so that meant a lot
so I'm glad you actually said yeah
so that's all I got on the question
front Lord it was tremendous do this on
hold for closeout and um whole this week
will be again xbox live really it's the
on-the-spot question so now for you this
will be so with the numerous consumer
friendly services and Xbox Live provides
which we've gone over do you think Xbox
allows you to doubt that tier level
pricing model the choice choices will be
a yes we love game pass and court
into the xbox live subscription be no
unless online multi-player is free at
the base level or see I don't care until
I see more exclusive games Lord Dan
McCullough an absolute pleasure to have
you in the realm of the absolutely
people feel free to let the Lords know
whatever you top secret things you may
be working on in the future so we can
find people find me there pretty much
everywhere else on Xbox on discord on
pretty much every game so nice I love
that tag by the way the random salute
pledge man we really appreciate what you
guys are doing we cannot speak enough of
absolutely the infrastructure of Xbox
Live and like I said it's been going on
for solely and you guys are the pioneers
of this let's just keep it a hundred
like you guys really push this thing
forward and got a lot of the rest of the
console market to follow suit and just
things I'm appreciative is like party
chat so many things that a lot of us
take for granted as gamers because let's
be realized the Lords we were all older
gamers and all that stuff didn't exist
we had to go to your friend's house you
have to you know link up not everybody's
married and moved away and we still are
able to communicate and play with each
other just like how it was in those days
with Halo one in the land party loop to
Microsoft salute the Lord in and the
Xbox Live team you guys do a tremendous
job don't get enough credit and we
definitely want to respect you to show
you that respect here so thanks again
for coming so all Lord addict what is
going on with you and we can't find
people find you I won't be streaming
because I'm determined to beat this
Shadow of the Colossus game I will give
them one thing man the game you know the
bosses might not
the bosses might be the highlight of the
game fighting the bosses there's there's
quite a bit of them statue there's a lot
like fur but I will say I've already
noticed some of them being reused but
you'll appreciate from and I appreciate
a you know Lord and for coming on the
show it's been an absolute pleasure and
yes Oliver you're wrong
so I know Lutz big shout out to Lord Dan
for coming through
you know xbox live more than it's
integral to the Xbox identity more than
any other service is to PlayStation or
Nintendo Xbox Live is the backbone of
Xbox and I it's very exciting to see
somebody with with Dan's like trajectory
his expertise at the helm of that his
head is higher for constantly creating
and and pushing tech forward that's
really excited for what Xbox Live is
it's doing now and in the future its I
have no doubt that whatever you guys
aspire to do in terms of streaming in
terms of whatever it is services it's
gonna be fantastic so I'm really glad
it's someone like you is at the helm of
that awesome
absolutely absolutely yes double down on
that statement Lord King what you have
going on what kind of find people find
you first I would like to address Lord
Dan a tremendous guy when I met him in
person
a humble energetic and enthusiastic
about what's coming forward and what's
next my only regret is I didn't have a
t-shirt for you right
oh yeah Dave debuted a fraud alert we're
gonna keep that poppin fraud alert will
definitely be on we had fights last
night nothing noteworthy like I said I
will not beginning to stuff that it's
not noteworthy but we did have a mention
of Deontay Wilder versus Tyson Fury and
that will be something I will go over to
our Instagram please how you find out
you have a lot of that I know you do
because I use pictures when you were
there and I know you have some we have a
lot of a lot of stuff up there like a
lot of the e3 shows pasty threes you
know packs is a lot of industry rooftop
party up there with Lord Lord arrested
crew you know a shout the Lord Megatron
oh and Lord and I forgot Lord $10 wanted
me to ask you how was it like meeting
the fans on that rooftop party yes
you know superfans before but this was
crap thank you so much I want to shout
out laws that were out there you know
you had a Tim dog beats fire you know
saying down Lord Megatron again I can't
think enough you know saying for getting
us out there as well I believe on from
2xp what's her name
mamacita was there l-boogie not me
bloody knuckles southbound man yeah but
the list goes on and on it was such a
good time Oh shout out to us a Rick I
got from warhorse studios yes yeah
tremendous fun and like I said one thing
you guys don't get enough credit for Dan
is that you guys the Xbox team is
probably one of the most personable fan
friendly teams I have been around
there's no Holly witness
there's no they make you feel like
family and that's one thing you also
want to thank you guys that really
really doesn't get into Freddie stated
so uh more company don't want Twitter
you already know and obviously the eye
Lord podcast YouTube channel we got some
stuff going on up there we got a new
flash point shout out to a Wilhelm
scream he was in the chat today he's in
definitely tower and he parties we had a
great episode talking that destiny talk
and of course a lot of other gaming
stuff so please check out that channel
as well and definitely hit the like
subscribe all that good stuff
um like hi bot so we'll have the audio
up on iTunes and a SoundCloud later I
also want to shout out the ILP stream
team Louis now though so you know Chad
old-school-style super-g and the amazing
lady l-boogie
please check them out when they are
stream on the ILP channel and last but
not least but I just want to thank you
know everyone for checking out the ILP
patreon you guys helped put out someone
asks try to put out some of these cool
content keep giving you that great
interviews and all that stuff you want
so thank you again for supporting it we
really really appreciate it
if any of the lord have anything else to
say and represent yeah of course this is
trash
I know everybody enjoy your Sunday
[Music]